Okay Michael, what's the answer?
>> Well, there's the answer to the question that
I thought you were asking and then there's the question
that you then at the end actually asked. It
seems like at the end you asked what is the
difference between the two, the distance between the two
lines and I I feel that, like that's just The,
like the norm of x1 minus x2. But, the difference
between these equations is going to be well ,uh, W transpose.
>> Well why not write down what you're, what you're telling over in the
side over here and then we can put the final answer in the box.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so what now?
>> W transpose. X1 minus x2, equals two.
>> Right, so you used ,ah, the power of subtraction
to make that work. Okay, very good. Okay, so that's
the difference between those two equations, now how am I
going to go from there to figuring out the distance between
x1 and x2?
>> I still feel like its just that norm of x1 minus x2.
>> Okay, but I want you to tell it to me
in terms of w. And what I want you to tell
it to me in terms of w, because the only thing
we have to play with here is w, well w and
b. That's what defines our line. And so I want to
find the right line, the only thing I get to play
with, W and b. So, I'd like to know something about
the relationship between w and the distance between x1 and x2.
>> Well, w transpose times their differences too.
>> [LAUGH] That's true.
>> That's not telling us the distance, though.
So what is the distance in terms of W?
>> Well what if I told you w was a number? What would you do if it was just a
simple scalar and you had this equation, and I wanted
to know what x1 minus x2 was. What would you do?
>> And I wanted it in terms of W?
>> Yeah, I wanted to know what x1 minus x2 was equal to.
>> Oh, I see.
So, if I divide it by w, that would be
helpful' cus then x1 minus x2 would be two over w.
>> Right, but you can't do that because w is a
vector, and you can't really divide by a vector, at least
not in the world that we're talking about. So how are
you going to... Make that work. Would you like a hint?
>> Sure.
>> Well here's a hint ,we want to move w over from one side to the other.
We could start doing all kinds of tricks with inverses, and
with the inverse of a vector. There's all kinds of things
that you could do, but actually the easiest thing way of
doing it is getting rid of w on one side. And
the easiest way to do that. Is to divide both sides
by the length of W. So, rather than dividing both sides
by W. We divide them by the length of W. Now
what is dividing W by the length of W, give you?
>> So, right. So W divided
by the length of W, is a normalized version of W. So it's like
Something that points in the same direction as W, but sits on the unit's sphere.
>> Right. No, that's exactly right! Alright, in fact it is a sphere
because it's a, it's a hyper sphere I suppose. right! So we do that
and that effectively is like giving you a value one, like you said it's a unit
sphere. And so now we're actually talking about the difference between
the vector X one and the vector X two projected onto
the unit sphere and that's equal to two over the [CROSSTALK].
>> Wait. That's what X minus two is
perjected onto the W vector The normalized W vector.
>> Right, the doubilized norm, the normalized
>> The double normalized U vector,
right
>> [LAUGH] So does that help you?
>> Does that actually answer the question? Doesn't seem like it does.
>> no, it does.
>> So is that, okay, alright, hang on [LAUGH] ,so ,the x one minus x two,
dotted with W. So W, W, we don't know. It could be anything. Can it? So.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We've taken x one minus x two, projected
it onto W. So it's like the, the length
of x one minus x two, but in the w direction.
>> Exactly. That's exactly right. So, the link, which, by the
way, is, well, is exactly right. So, what we've just done is
we have found the link of x1 and x2 in the W
direction. What do we know about w with relationship to the line?
>> W is the parameter to the line.
>> Yes, but in particular. As with, in the case with any
hyper plane, W actually represents a vector that's perpendicular to the line.
>> And since we chose X1 and X2, so that they would in fact, their
distance or the difference, would in fact
be perpendicular to the line. What we've just
done is projected. That rose the difference
between those two vectors onto something that is
also perpendicular to the line. And so what that ends up giving us is, in fact,
its length. So we maximize the length. Of x1 minus x2 with doing what with W.
>> I see so the thing on the left is,infact, have we answered
the quiz yet by the way, or are we still working on that?
>> I'm going to say we are still working on it.
>> Oh men ,alright this is a hard quiz. The thing on left, not just
were the braces are, that actually turns out
to be the distance between the two. Hyperplanes.
>> Right, let's let's give that a letter. Let's call it M.
>> Mm.
>> And, we're saying that equals two over the norm of W. And
that's, so, if we want to maximize that The only thing that we have
to play with is W and that is made larger and larger as
W gets smaller and smaller, in other words, pushing it toward the origin.
>> Right.
>> So it set Ws to all zeroes, and we should be golden.
>> Right, except if we push all the Ws to zero, we might not be
able to correctly classify our points but what this does tell us is that we have
a way of thinking about The distance of
this vector and where the decision boundary ought
to be. We want to find the parameters of
the hyperplane such that we, maximize this distance
over here represented by this equation while still being
consistent with the data. Which makes sense because that's actually
what we said in the first place. By the
way, this thing has a name and it's. The reason
why I chose M, it's called the margin, and
what all of this exercise tells you is that your
goal is to find a decision boundary that maximizes
the margin, subject to the constraint that you actually want
to correctly classify everything, and that is represented
by that term. Now somehow, it feels like
having gone through all this we outta be
able to use it for something and turn in
into some other problem we might be able
to solve. Might be able to maximize for ,uh,
so that we can actually find the best line. And it turns out we can do that.
>> Have we answered the quiz yet?
>> Oh yeah we did. Which is in fact what I wanted so the answer is.
>> Wow.
Somebody gets that, that would be pretty impressive.
>> That would be very impressive. Or
anything similar to this I would accept. [LAUGH]
In fact I probably better will. Okay good. So, it turns out
that this whole notion of thinking about finding the optimal. Decision boundary
is the same as finding a line that maximizes the margin. And
we can take what we've just learned, where we've decided the goal is
to maximize two over the length of w and turn
it into a problem where we can solve this directly.